the Blair Witch Project came out in 1999
and was a massive success this is what
every kid in my school was talking about
back in 99 I remember going to school
and having kids tell me they went to
this movie with their parents of course
trying to figure out how many f-words
were in this film one kid came to school
proclaiming he had counted all of the F
words and he was so proud of that and I
thought it'd be fun to talk about the to
theatrical Blair Witch films this one
and the Book of Shadows film before the
new Blair Witch reboot comes out later
in September there was a gargantuan
amount of secrecy surrounding this film
the marketing was on point a lot of
people genuinely thought this was real
authentic footage of three teenagers who
got lost in the woods searching for the
famed Blair Witch and so for that reason
there are really two groups of people
who watch this film people who saw it
perhaps back in 99 for the very first
time watched it in theaters who were
terrified there was this aura
surrounding the film of is it real or is
it not real and that really added a lot
of weight to the movie and to the
experience and a lot of critics back in
the day called it one of the scariest
movies ever made because that added
sense of is this real or is this not
real definitely helped the film I didn't
see it in theaters back in 99 I saw it
for the first time at home when everyone
knew it was fake when everyone knew it
was just a film made by some very clever
filmmakers and I appreciated the film
for what it was but the second group of
people are the people who have heard the
hype of this movie for years who have
constantly heard about it who maybe even
grew up hearing about it and then
watched her for the first time and said
nothing happened what the hell there was
no music there's no witch in the film
you don't see anything nothing ever
really happens it's just some annoying
people who get lost in the woods and
that group of people tend to hate the
Blair Witch Project and so this movie
has a lot of things going for it
and some things not going forward I
actually did get a chance to see this
movie in theaters because a really cool
independent theater by my house called
the nightlight did a witch series and
the Blair Witch was one of the films
they chose and I got to see it in
theaters and it's definitely a different
experience when those lights go down and
you're suddenly surrounded by
the sounds captured by this very
low-quality footage it's different all
these years later when you watch it at
home because it doesn't hold that power
or that weight and even though nothing
really does happen in the film what I
think works best about the Blair Witch
Project is the three main performances
as well as the sense of realism these
actors are very good they are giving
very good performances and you really
can't argue with that because surveys
were done about how many people actually
believe this was authentic real
documentary footage many people thought
it was real a lot of people bought into
it and a lot of that is due to these
excellent performances the filmmakers
went to such extreme extents to put
missing flyers around the various
festivals that this film showed act
adding to the confusion if these kids
were really missing or not also it was
one of the first films to receive a
viral marketing campaign you went on the
website and you can learn things you
could read behind the scenes information
about the supposed Blair Witch lore as
well as see missing photos of these kids
and if you read the IMDB trivia for this
film you can actually see in the trivia
section that the mother of Heather
Donahue received sympathy cards because
genuinely people thought her daughter
was missing or maybe even dead that's
how much people bought into this film
back in the late 90s it was a pop
culture phenomenon does it hold up as
well not as much because now we know
it's not real and we've seen a slew of
imitators in the found-footage format
that give us more dramatically and
thematically then The Blair Witch
Project gave us so it doesn't have the
best replay value but that's actually
also a big plus that it doesn't give us
as much drama in as much scary moments
because that makes it seem more real it
seems more grounded in reality that
we're watching events that are real
because nothing big and larger than life
and very movie like happens in the film
and so it does in a way feel real it was
also one of the most vastly profitable
movies of all time made for an
incredibly small budget that really
anyone could actually pull off nowadays
with the technology that's available to
us anyone really with a knowledge of how
to make a film could make the Blair
Witch Project today so it's kind of
crazy that somebody didn't think of
this idea sooner than they did but these
guys man did they make Bank they even
returned the camera they bought from
Circuit City got a refund on it to make
their budget go even farther that's
crazy
one of my favorite bits of info about
this movie is that The Blair Witch was
actually supposed to show up there's a
scene in the film where the characters
run out of their tent and I believe it's
Heather says oh my god oh my god what is
that the cameraman was supposed to pan
to the left and there was going to be
like a woman standing up on like this
high Hill area in like a white gown they
didn't pan to the left and they never
reshot it but the Blair Witch was
supposed to be in the movie for just one
little bit that being said the finale of
this movie is chilling there is
something absolutely startling and
bothersome about the way the film ends
and if you've never seen it I won't ruin
it for you but it harkens back to things
that people in the town said in the
beginning of the film and it ties
together nicely to leave a very chilling
feeling inside of you
some people may refer to this film as a
classic simply because of what it
started simply because of how effective
it was when it was initially released I
wouldn't go that far I think it's a very
effective found footage movie with three
really good performances and a genuine
sense of creepiness but it doesn't hold
up as much all these years later because
we've been exposed to so many other
found footage films that are technically
better but in the same way as I said
that kind of works as a strength for
this movie because it does feel more
realistic I'm going to give the Blair
Witch Project of B
guys stay tuned so I'm going to have a
review for Book of Shadows Blair Witch -
that's actually a film I'm excited to
talk about because it has a very strange
story behind it there are two Book of
Shadows films one that the director was
trying to make and one the studio wanted
what we got was the one the studio
wanted I want to also talk about what
the director was trying to do and the
hopes that maybe one day we'll get a
director's cut I'm excited to talk about
that very soon you guys are the best
thank you very much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes